don't watch it anymore just stop
watching don't care don't watch it I
don't do anything in reality TV I'm just
done
well it kind of seems like you watch it
dude because yeah bad Chad is at it
again and honestly it's amazing this guy
can still make headlines but alas he
went on a wild Twitter rant
calling out tons of bachelor nation
stars like Tyler Cameron Ben Higgins and
oh yeah Sara Harun which is where it
will start oh that one on [ __ ] okay we
all remember that bachelor in paradise
moment and now chad is saying that he
never said that quote I recently learned
that I never called Sara a quote
one-armed be the audio was cut spliced
and edited together from multiple
conversations I apologized for three
years for something I never even did
beyond from there Dean and Sara both got
involved
Dean caused him a trash human Sara sankt
Dean but Chad came back with receipts
revealing these alleged text messages
between him and Sara and claiming she
was interested in him yikes and it
doesn't stop there
Chad poked fun of Tyler C's upcoming
food tour charity quote it takes
impoverished kids to nice restaurants to
show them what they can't have
while Tyler gets a nice picture for
Instagram then dumps them right back
where they came
he also pokes fun at his relationship
with Gigi Hadid with this metaphor quote
dating Gigi Hadid is like driving Enzo
Ferraris personal Honda Civic yes it has
a good story will get you where you want
to go but at the end of the day it is
still just an average Honda Civic has he
seen Gigi Hadid Chad also insulted Ben
Higgins podcast claiming he only makes
20 grand a year from it to which Ben
actually responded saying that's just
not true
Chad also took aim at Colton Underwood
and Chris Harrison but is this even an
insult I can't and oh yeah he is still
holding a grudge against Daniel from his
season of The Bachelorette
but I don't think any of us care anymore
so I'm just not gonna bore you with
reading those alright guys what do you
make of Chad's rants please let me know
and for all the latest on bachelor
nation keep it locked to all things 80
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye
for now
you
[Applause]
[Music]